procès qui débute aujourd'hui c'est au
tribunal correctionnel de versailles
celui de la filière française d'ikea
mise en cause pour avoir instauré un
système d'espionnage de ses salariés
elle révélait en 2012 par le canard
enchaîné par mediapart
l' affaire instruite après une plainte
d'un syndicat l' affaire avait ébranlé
la branche française du géant du
mobilier suédois contraintes de
licencier quatre hauts responsables
après huit ans d'enquêté le groupe ainsi
qu'une quinzaine de personnes physiques
dont des cadres de la firme et des
policiers comparaissent devant la
justice soupçonnait d'avoir passé au
crible les antécédents judiciaires ou
train de vie de plusieurs centaines de
personnes dont des syndicalistes
le procès doit durer jusqu'au 2 avril
ils ont mis en place toute une stratégie
pour nous faire perdre pour nous faire
perdre tous nous faire pas de la tête
nous nous sortir dj key à nous faire
virer voilà c'est ça a été vraiment une
grosse une grosse machine qui sait qu'à
marcher sur nous quoi j'ai tout le temps
comme harcelé tout le temps que j'étais
suivi personnes bull n 3 mais maintenant
quand j'ai donné la clé usb aux
journalistes et après que mon camarade à
donner ça à la justice
là tout le monde a vu que monsieur amara
n'était pas par ailleurs à paranoïaque
et afu il ya un droit en france et que
l'entreprise n'a pas respecté elle se
produit des lois et c'est hors de
question et en plus tout ce système a
été mis en place
nous on considère ces pour nuire aux
salariés parce que quel est l'intérêt
sinon de faire des recherches sur son
sur ses antécédents sur sa vie privée
sur ses comptes bancaires ce n'est pas
pour lui nuire
mais ça on peut pas l'accepter une oie
cégétiste tout simplement le véritable
procès doit déterminer l'ampleur du
système mise en place et si jamais le
système était généralisé aux ordres de
kitsch bref comment contrôler les
salariés sur dévasté privée et qu'on
n'avait pas avoir beaucoup il fait
consciente que trois prévenus le procès
aura bien lieu
je suis assez confiant oui